oh my god i had no idea
holy crap i had no idea this is
telling oh [ __ ] holy crap that's telling
what's going on reject nation greg and
john here so as we're prepping to do an
interview with the director of willy's
wonderland which by the way thank you to
everyone who saw our movie reaction for
that if you haven't seen it go ahead and
check that out we got an interview here
from vanity fair for the director of the
snyder cut zack snyder himself and
apparently the
headline for this is justice league the
shocking exhilarating heartbreaking true
story of the snyder cut and a lot of
people send this article over to me i
heard mention
of something called jesus joker i hear
the photos in here so what we're gonna
do
obviously because i'm sure that's what
everyone really cares for us to go check
out first so we'll get that out of the
way
big reaction i'm gonna scroll through
this article to see where that photo is
afterwards we'll go through this article
we're gonna read through everything from
beginning to end in real time
but you know i'll be jump cutting around
it all right so we got the article here
that is galvado that's a oh that's 300.
oh
oh my okay oh
all right it's jesus surgeon damn i
heard jesus joker i didn't know what
they're that has the crown of thorns
and everything wow oh my god this is
going to be literally a really
jam-packed dream in terms of symbolism
jesus jesus jesus
oh goodness oh that is nuts that's
gnarly
yeah i'm not sure how to feel about this
right now
just looks that much more like marilyn
manson
this looks like a marilyn manson album
cover i mean
zack snyder definitely does a lot of
religious symbolism
especially in regard i don't know if
this article will go into it but
especially in regards to jesus i mean i
feel like that's such a go-to
thing with superman especially they did
it in i think even the pilot of
smallville
they do it in superman returns zack
snyder definitely doesn't shy away from
that and man of steel as well
and jesus symbolism is one of the most
go-to things i think in a lot of movies
and such
i guess the last thing we were expecting
is for it to be associated with
joker of all characters so in that
sequence this is a new one that they
shot for this
batman in order to get help he has to
put all ego to the side
and turn to the last person he ever
expected to turn to for help
and saving the world and that's joker so
and it's supposed to be a dream sequence
so it's not not
real you know he's not going to show up
looking like this this could just be
like a quick flash of something
either joker is mocking him as like i'm
your new savior or something like that
yeah or just me being the way i am
existing outside of any and all
paradigms is what will save you know
whatever circumstances or something
or maybe it'll be just left over to some
interpretation yeah or maybe they'll
just be in a church and it'll be really
in your face i heard jesus joker i
thought joker with a beard
that would be a new take on joker and it
would certainly be befitting of jared
leto
the crown of thorns is a little bit like
oh oh you mean
jesus joker i i feel like people wonder
if people are mad
of course people will be mad i mean
symbolism is one thing having
superman fly out of something or fall
with his arms out like this for saving
the world
is one thing but it's written large in a
way but this is
very much slam bam in your face
jesus joker this wants to provoke you we
didn't even talk about the article we
could just talk about this jesus joker
the whole time
to get two videos wow
i'll have to wait to see how it goes uh
i'm not sure how to feel about this
right now
i mean he said the joker's gonna you
know try and deconstruct
batman so maybe in that way he's gonna
like use this to get under his skin or
something maybe he'll dress up as batman
at one point
that would be i think we're gonna see
him in a wide variety of costumes
oh so is this the hospital gowned outfit
and he's wearing the crown of thorns
right here yeah i thought that was like
the jesus
not rope that's what it is and he's got
the mask too like the surgical
masculinity loves jesus didn't have uh
kitchen gloves we don't know that
this is true jesus was a hypochondriac
you don't know that you know what
bethlehem was really like and who got
his place
all right well it's breezing through
this it doesn't look like the article
talks about it so that's out of the way
let's talk about the article now
in late 2017 months after the couple cut
ties of the superhero epic amid an
increasingly demoralizing battle with
warner brothers deborah snyder
sat in a screening room on the studio
lot alongside christopher nolan
who hates warner brothers now one of the
movie's executive producers as well as
the director of the dark knight trilogy
she braced herself as the lights went
down it was just a weird experience
i don't know how many people have had
that experience you've worked on
something for so long and then you leave
and then you see what happened to it i'm
leaving at the end of the month for
colorado
john's gonna be in charge of john's
hands for a week so i'm gonna have a
very similar experience
yeah yeah and you're going to be on that
flight next to christopher nolan
what happens after their private
screening of the weeding cut nolan and
deborah center emerge into the light
with a shared mission they came and they
just said
you can never see that movie
in the warner herzog voice from grizzly
man you must never watch this type
and then deborah added because i knew it
would break his heart
absolutely yeah oh my god nightmare
so then you're talking about amidst this
time that autumn took her own
life which obviously created a major
conflict for zach and deborah while
working on the movie
it's such a lightning strike in the
center of this whole saga snyder says of
his daughter autumn's death it has
informed everything we've done
since their daughter's death was the
reason the snyders walked away from
justice
league realizing their fight and spirit
was needed at home you know i feel like
this is such a neglected part of the
story
absolutely because yes there was already
studio
conflicts and issues that zach and
deborah were battling with warner
brothers and such this is a part of the
story that seems to
just kind of fly under the radar when
this was a big reason why he didn't
continue to fight for it
yeah and i mean i think a lot of people
might easily forget
that it's moments like these that remind
you about you know what's really
important
in life you know and that article says
now she is the main reason he decided to
come back
oh at the end of the movie it says for
autumn
i mean yeah i mean yes we well all of us
could have a lot of us could have
expected that but that's still really
sweet to know that that's actually here
without her
this absolutely would not have happened
oh wow
the article then talks about how from
being with denise weber
and kirsten ellen before and the amount
of children that zack snyder
ultimately has had a lot of them being
adopted
and the filmmakers often said being an
adoptive father is one of the reasons he
was so
invested in the story of carl a powerful
being who became superman thanks to the
love and care of jonathan and martha
kent you know people were always like
you just wanted to make a batman movie
but i'm like he's always loved superman
and it's actually pretty neat to know
that this is a big reason why absolutely
and why he really seems to
love jonathan kennedy yeah yeah that
character in particular
because he's jonathan yeah i think he
views himself less as superman and more
as jonathan cannon
that actually really clicks now more
than three years after autumn's death
snyder still slips between the past and
present tense when talking about her
she's the only dork she was the only fan
the rest of them
he shrugs today eli is interested in
filmmaking but autumn was one of the
only children who matched her dad's
kid-like enthusiasm for gods monsters
aliens and superheroes
man that is that's heartbreaking she's
super creative
she was a writer she was at sarah
lawrence to be a writer
wow snyder swipes through his phone to
show a selfie autumn took in the
letterman jacket worn by ray fisher's
character in justice league
wow okay so i don't know some puzzle
pieces are starting to click together
in terms of what is so personal for him
yeah especially
wow it's really starting to click wow
this is a really good article guys
it's a really long one and in depth but
he goes pretty much into big depth about
uh his daughter
autumn talking about how when dealing
with her depression things about like
she would say what is
my worth what am i supposed to do what
am i about uh the conversation was like
of course you're amazing what do you
mean you're worth you're worth more
anything in this world and she would
just be like
yeah she adored sci-fi her main
characters are always in this battle
with things from another dimension that
no one can see
but it's a serious war and that war was
happening to her every day
i think so many people are in that
battle and they smile and nod at you
this is this is actually a lot this is
rough to read yeah
someone as someone who's struggled with
depression for his whole life this is
really
really rough the fact that a studio had
lost faith in snyder's ability to make
justice leasing mundane and pointless
after autumn's death
that makes sense so eventually he left
the project
obviously from a lot of the
circumstances that were a lot of us are
aware about so as this article goes
through
the trajectory of starting from man of
steel the reception that a lot of us are
very much aware about with batman v
superman he talks a lot about in-depth
guys go check out the article
talks a lot about in depth about how
nbvs the the fan reception how
disheartening that was
yet how it all led to even films like
suicide squad and birds of prey that
still exist within the universe that he
created
how he made like bold decisions with
casting jason momoa as aquaman when the
studios were like i don't know about
that and gal gadot when she was
considering quitting the business
entirely
so i mean he's made some bold choices
that undoubtedly i think have done dc
better in the long run so like to sum it
up diane nelson
who is president of dc entertainment
time says she appreciated that snyder
was more
in into deconstructing the familiar than
just
recapitulating it zach is a masterful
visual storyteller who goes deep on
individual characters for some people
that is amazing and for other people
that becomes a problem because they have
fixed opinions about who these dc
characters are
and are not i don't know jesus joker
that's the definitive take i've been
waiting for all these years
okay this is interesting because you
know all the stories about john berg and
jeff
johns that have been coming to light
recently uh snyder says
he knew why john and berg were on the
set you could babysit he says
many filmmakers would have bristled at
the intrusion but he was gracious it
didn't bother me too much because they
weren't that threatening i just felt the
ideas they did have
were they were trying to inject humor
and stuff like that it wasn't anything
that was that was too outrageous
but warner oh this is okay but warner
brothers did nix some of his more
sweeping notions for justice league like
adding a romance what i did not know
about
any of this any of this been leaked ben
affleck's bruce wayne and amy adams
lois lane who was mourning superman's
death in the previous film the intention
was that bruce fell in love with lois
and then whoa this is wild this is like
an injustice story though yeah
and i realized that the only way to save
the world was to bring superman back to
life
so he had this insane conflict because
lois of course was still in love with
superman
we had this beautiful speech where bruce
said alfred i never had a life outside
the cave
i never imagined a world for me beyond
this but this woman makes me think that
if i can get this group of gods together
and my job is done
i can quit i can stop and of course that
doesn't work out for him it didn't work
out for snyder either the studio said no
i don't know man that actually sounds
really interesting well yeah because at
first you go wait
what is the lowest that's crazy then you
hear it you're like oh man that's kind
of an interesting card
yeah it means that he's got to bring
superman back and that yeah he can
actually reach some kind of
resting point of fulfillment as a
character you're like that's kind of
ambitious i'd like to see that
so true you know it's also true i just
got an energy drink juice in my eye
oh what's that you have like supervision
now no
no just pain pain among the issues with
those length of the film there was a
mandate
from shujihara that the movie be two
hours long that order had a paradoxical
impact because it meant eliminate much
of the heart and the humor the studio
wanted like a comical romantic subplot
between
flash and iris and the latter of whom
was absent entirely from the whedon film
that sounds like the kind of frictions
you would run into because like how do
you add all that stuff without taking
time for it so how am i supposed
to introduce six characters and an alien
with potential for world domination in
two hours
i mean i i can do it it can be done
clearly it was done referred to whedon's
version but i didn't see it it wasn't
done
well for most people that's for sure it
was done
somehow oh
this is telling oh [ __ ]
about this weed and stuff oh no oh damn
i just breezed a couple sentences holy
crap that's telling
reports that snyder himself asked whedon
for help were false
john's one of the studio appointed
babysitters have been planning a batgirl
movie with whedon and snyder and others
say john's occurred him to do rewrites
for justice league once again
snyder was gracious and even hopeful i
thought maybe he could write some cool
scenes i thought that would be fun
damn soon it became clear that warner
brothers was giving
whedon more and more power he would not
just advise during reshoots but also do
some directing himself
holy [ __ ] while snyder was on set
snyder says he only had one conversation
with whedon about the studio's notes
reeling from autumn's death and finding
anguish in their work rather than relief
zach and deborah quit oh my god
i had no idea holy crap i had no idea
that's really i thought it was he left
and then whedon came in but damn whedon
was already there while snyder was
making me
yeah they were like fading him in oh
[ __ ]
they were like literally doing it while
the man was still on set
that is wild yeah that's gotta hurt i
mean like
you know it's business and all that
stuff but like that it doesn't seem very
ethical
in terms of just like leadership you
know we just lost the will to fight that
fight in a lot of ways
a lot of us the whole family were just
so broken by losing autumn that having
those conversations
in the middle of it became like i was
like really frankly i think we did the
right thing because i think it would
have been either incredibly belligerent
or we just rolled over
wow yeah oh that is not right yo
i'm more excited for this time we're
good now than ever
damn that is not cool okay so then we
got this quote here from a studio
executive who requested
an um and an an aninoy mini
anonymity you're wrong when we got to
see that joss
when we got to see what joss actually
did it was
stupid it's the roof the rubber on the
rooftop
uh so goofy stupefying the robber on the
rooftop
so goofy and awful the russian family is
so useless and pointless everyone knew
it it was so awkward because nobody
wanted to meet what a piece
wanted to admit what a piece of [ __ ] it
was why did they say something new
yeah like how would they not be even
more up in arms realizing that they just
messed up
worse than they already did and then of
course you know we know the journey
of what ended up happening eventually as
zach took time away
and then the snyder cut movement came to
fruition
and then airplanes and banners and
people being shot out of rockets
for the snyder when the capital happened
uh
capital riots it was all good all about
the schneider cut that's what it really
was
they're like we've already green lit
yeah it's coming already
see these ads we keep dropping when we
get into the discussion about
the toxicity of snyder cut fandom
there's a really great quote from here
from this psychologist named drea
letta mende what i have observed is an
enduring false sense of ownership
which can manifest as abuse threats and
strong intense reactions when a story
doesn't go their way
fighting for the unseen cut of the film
became a cause in some quarters the
worst behavior
metastasized they're shouting and people
are listening to them even if it's
negative comments they're getting
positive reinforcement to continue down
that path
when a big studio is like let's destroy
an entire movie to play
you guys you know snyder cringes at
descriptions of the abusive tactics i
100
think it's wrong i don't think that
anyone should be calling anyone anything
i've always
tried to give people in the phantom
attention to do good things and of
course as
everything started going and then
eventually toby emerick chairman of
warner brothers sat down with snyder and
talked about what's another way they can
do this
eventually we got to the point where
we're at right now but here's a really
interesting part holy crap that is
there's so many interesting things in
here initially says snyder warner
brothers just wanted to release the raw
footage on his laptop what a dick move
finish it yourself fans i was like
that's a no
that's a hard note and they're like but
why you could just put up the rough cut
snyder didn't trust their motivations i
go here's why three reasons
one you get the internet off your back
which is probably your main reason for
wanting to do this
two you get to feel vindicated for
making things right
i guess on some level and then three you
get a shitty version of the movie they
can point at and go
see it's not that good anyway so maybe i
was right
i was like no chance i would rather just
have the cider cup be a mythical unicorn
for all time first
respect no yeah i think it's it's things
right that's
a terrible idea he's 100 right about
that
other way do you interpret that for a
movie of that
size and budgetary scale no
no how else would you interpret that you
released that in like a hundred years
for free or something
oh this is wild snyder estimates that it
costs around 70 million dollars to undo
whedon's redo for that hbo maxed its
four hours of hotly anticipated
reprogramming the hollywood comeback
story of a lifetime yet
snyder himself gets nothing i'm not
getting paid oh he says he was paid the
first time of course this time
he wants creative control and foregoing
a fee
helped i didn't want to be beholden to
anyone and allow me to keep my
negotiating powers and these people
pretty strong
damn dude this is solely a passion
project yep
this point is become that and fight for
what you feel wronged for wow you know
i i gotta say man i am more excited than
ever for this i love
every zack snyder film now hey the fact
that he doesn't want any money for this
is
no garlic and he's he's putting in the
most time and effort yeah he literally
went
we could do this the absolute wrong way
or i'll come back and do it the right
way for free but
but yeah wow yeah big respect the snyder
movement has contributed half a million
dollars to the american foundation for
suicide prevention through donations
sales of merchandise and auction and
props people have been saying oh they
attack people says zebra snyder
their eyes tearing but this fan base has
saved lives as much as they wanted
something for themselves
they've come together for this and come
together actually
they come together for this amazing
cause
um it was more like i shouldn't make a
joke during this quote
also also humanity you feel so helpless
trying to help
someone and you don't know what to do
it's literally life or death
and i felt like we didn't really know
where to turn
this is so gnarly to me okay so then it
ends off with rebuilding the story he
had always envisioned and what
invigorates center the most he can go as
deep and dark as he likes he can say
hell the dc's
official timeline for the characters and
let this alt version of the justice
league story wind up
wherever he pleases he has put superman
in sleek black slew
suit instead of the iconic blue and red
he's added the joker jared leto
he has re-shot the ending with a hero
cameo that will blow hardcore fans minds
mufus though
[Laughter]
what may be a device that would be the
ultimate mic drop
he also presented the movie in the boxy
4x3 format rather than a wide screen so
that one day it can be watched on imac
screens
you see that's cool so when imax
theaters reopened then we could get a
re-release of this up
i think that's really cool and i bet
that helped his case with wp
get those expensive tickets the director
is also layering in some deeply personal
elements the movie closes with leonard
cohen's hallelujah performed by allison
crowe
who also sang it at autumn's funeral wow
this is like a big tribute to her as
well it was autumn's favorite song now
it's an elegy to her
justice league however anyone else feels
about it it's made of the things and
people snyder loves too
when you think about the catharsis of it
if i was a potter i would have made some
pottery to look for some ways through
this but i'm a filmmaker so you get this
giant movie
he wants people to love it some don't
he's all right with that with all of it
whatever it comes he's okay what is my
worth
what am i supposed to do what am i about
zack snyder's answering autumn's
questions for himself wow wow so
i mean i think this is absolutely
heartbreaking and it's beautiful
and there's some real surprising things
in here and to also see
how we're diving into this article we're
diving into autumn
and the story that happened there with
her she never thought they'd really get
all
personal or um specific about which they
didn't get too specific but
i always thought those details they
would reserve uh like any and all and
then you come to find out that
oh it's because it's all kind of part of
the cycle here of what led to this
movement and how
they stepped away from this movie for
her and now they're making this and it
ends
for her yeah that's beautiful it's
fascinating to kind of look at all these
facts presented and to look at it
through this lens of like
it does seem like a truly human endeavor
because you know
before this all happened it's just like
oh they're clashing heroes and stuff
together but now especially reading
those remarks about autumn and whatnot
like it does almost seem like yeah maybe
especially being able to go back and
add to his previous cut he probably was
able to
work out yeah some of that anguish and
grief
through this story through those you
know invisible fantasy worlds like he
he referenced and yeah like it kind of
confirms in a way
the horror story you hear about how much
of a cold heartless machine hollywood
can be
and it's interesting and refreshing and
heartening in some ways to see
that you know for whatever you debate
about zack snyder's
content his movies philosophies or
whatever
he does seem like a really human guy
who does want to make just like really
passionate art
you know whatever that may be and and
yeah i do appreciate like for all of
this
i feel like he could have walked away
and just left it forever but he's used
this
terrible situation for a lot of good
things and ultimately i feel like that
has paid off through the snyder cut you
know it's like
it's the weird ultimate reward that we
can all get a catharsis
it's like now i never expected to be
like damn i might have like an emotional
experience during this night
oh wow that's beautiful what do you
think about this article there's a link
in the description box
for it i'd read the whole thing in
detail you know because we have to with
the jump cut around this
when i read the whole thing in detail
yeah leave your thoughts down below
subscribe hit that like button keep a
lookout for a review for the snyder cut
when it does come out
march 18th see you guys soon